sanchez 36 years of age the native of
archive venezuela 2-2 from on ebal
and he has harper way out in front
35th strikeout in just over 43 innings
two down
runner on the move and the throw is on
target
it looked a little late and then it
looks like he came off the bag
vic carapazza took his time
didn't make a call and alec baum
evidently came off the bag and got
tacked out zach will 4-0 2.62 era second
start since his pant problem here's
andrew stevenson 308 hitter in there
leading off with the nets tonight
that is right over the bag
it's going to get right off the very
corner of the stands there
and andrew stevenson has a five-game
hitting streak slapping a double since a
corner situation far as jubal cabrera
up the middle hard hit enough to get
through
stevenson scores soto stops at second
and as drupal does make it to 30 rbis
first inning of the nets on top
there goes holt the throw goes through
and it's into right center field
so a steal and an error will score juan
soto and then actually two nothing
swinging to miss 97 blew it right by him
and the side is retired then he battles
back to fill the count
swing and a miss
sanchez battles back for a second
strikeout
oh my what a jump
and then making it close and getting him
is kurt suzuki you talk about a makeup
throw
i don't think gene segurk can believe
he's out at second base after the jump
he got
[Applause]
swagger to miss
second strikeout for wheeler who threw
34 pitches in inning one
[Music]
swing at a miss he went around that's a
high fast ball
2-2 pitch and a fastball call strike
three he gets trey turner looking in the
side he's retired
and a strike three called on the inside
corner
roman down looking three strikeouts
sanchez
and joe has been thrown out of the game
third inning of the game though he's
gonna stay in the game
[Applause]
sanchez has it
turner turns it
against a speedy runner one six three
there's drupal cabrera's coming up
swag in a miss he went out of the strike
zone
[Applause]
and that's five strikeouts for wheeler j
bruce three for 17 career against une
ball
paint on the outside edge
sanchez is out of the inning bottom
third of the order for the nats who have
a two-nothing lead
that's way gonna miss that is a
beautiful pitch the change-up
[Applause]
seven strikeouts looks like he's finding
it a woman here kind of long counts for
on ebal tonight but the bottom line he's
got four zeros up on the board of only
three hits two two
got him front door on the hook
strikeout number five and two runners
aboard with bryce harper coming up just
the way the phillies
drew it up
that's a ball that'll give the phils a
run nobody's covering first montyack
will score it's a 2-1 game
and it cost him right there
wow
and then harper strikes out sanchez
giving up a run on four hit struck out
for walk four and committed a bunk
to the right side wheeler can't get it
kingry does flips with the glove in time
what a play
kingry had a couple really good plays in
this sitting first and third one out
garcia the hitter
that's a fair ball
and it's going to bring in a run how
about that
maybe 30 feet up the line cabrera scores
and the nets
by two again lake parker is on for the
philly
and a call strike three right at the
bottom of the zone and the side is
retired
oh and then a nice pick by cabrera now
we've got a rundown
3-6-3
on the double play
as drooble picked it cleanly and that
is an important play in this game and
now the line moves to brock holt
who singled up the middle this last time
oh the runner going at second trade
turner he had quite a jump then he had
to freeze the line drive went through
and that ball gets away the gnats will
score two on this play unbelievable and
the nets lead five to one and with
mickey moniak stepping in the tying run
is suddenly in the on deck circle
that will do it
hudson
ends it with a 97 mile an hour fastball
nice tidy 5-1 win